je voudrais toutefois avant toute chose
vous dire qu'en tant que préfet de
police je suis le seul responsable
opérationnel de l'ordre et de la
sécurité publique sur l'agglomération
parisienne et c'est à dire
l'agglomération parisienne c'est paris
et les trois départements de la petite
couronne je ne suis d'ailleurs pas le
préfet de police de paris je suis le
préfet de police tout court on puisqu'en
l'occurrence le sujet concerne la seine
saint denis je vais très clair là dessus
les préfets de départements de la petite
couronne n'ont aucune compétence en
matière d'ordre et de sécurité publique
les fonctionnaires de police et les
militaires de gendarmerie qui
interviennent le font donc sous mon
autorité directe ou sous sol que je
donne par délégation a dit aux
fonctionnaires qui toi du corps
préfectoral ou de la police
j'assume donc en totalité la
responsabilité de la gestion policière
de la journée du samedi 28 mai et je le
répète encore une fois j'en suis devant
vous mais également devant le pays le
seul comptable opérationnel ceux qui ont
agi l'ont fait sous mon commandement je
les dis et je veux d'abord les saluer
policiers ou gendarmes ils ont fait
preuve d'une énergie et d'une volonté ce
soir là comme à l'accoutumée que je
voudrais ici souligné sans eux un drame
aurait pu se produire je leur fait donc
part publiquement comme je lé fais plus
indirectement de ma reconnaissance pour
leurs actions et de ma fierté de les
avoir sous mes ordres ils ne sont pas
pour moi des troupiers expression d'un
siècle passé que l'on associe plutôt mot
comique même si elle ne me fait pas rire
mais les collègues ou des camarades
d'une grande valeur professionnelle et
morale
n'éludant pas mes responsabilités je
regarde ou du moins j'essaye de regarder
avec la plus grande lucidité
possible ce qui s'est passé autour du
stade de france ce soir là
c'est à l'évidence un échec car des
personnes ont été boostées les agresser
alors que nous leur devions la sécurité
c'est un échec aussi car l'image du pays
vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
président a été ébranlée
mais je dois insister au delà de cet
échec sur le fait que face à une crise
d'ampleur dans un contexte dégradé est
difficile nous avons fait en sorte que
le match se tiennent et surtout surtout
qu'il n'y ait aucun blessé grave et
aucun mort
qui plus est sur paris intra muros temps
sur la circulation des supporters que
sur la fan zone ou bien hors de paris
sur les aéroports eux même temps de
roissy et d'orly il n'y a eu aucun
incident significatif
je vous disait avoir conscience que
l'image de la france a été atteinte
c'est une blessure pour moi car l'amour
de la patrie et l'honneur du drapeau
compte plus que tout à nos hôtes
étrangers qu'ils soient espagnols ou
anglais qui ce soir là n'ont pas tous
trouvé les conditions sur d'un accueil
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
français je veux dire également mes
regrets sincères
[Musique]